[Music]
[Music]
hello i'm nick clark this is counter the
cost on al jazeera your weekly look at
the world of business and economics this
week
spending more money to buy guns many
european nations turn to american-made
weapons after russia's invasion of
ukraine so what's behind the increase in
defense spending and who's reaping the
profit
also this week the ukraine crisis is
disrupting global trade and it's coming
for the car industry keeve halted half
of the world's neon output needed for
vehicle microchips our car makers going
to cope
sub-saharan africa is the world's least
connected region but google's underwater
cable aims to improve internet access to
the region can the project really help
millions of africans connect to the rest
of the world
all right peace has existed for decades
across much of europe since world war ii
but russia's invasion of ukraine has
alerted the continent that it is not
guaranteed there have been calls for an
eu army and many european countries are
now reassessing their defence policies
several governments have already
increased their military budgets some of
them significantly germany alone has
announced it will allocate more than 110
billion us dollars to military funding
and that marked a major policy shift now
the nation has approached the us to buy
f-35 fighter jet capable of carrying
nuclear weapons
poland also wants to purchase
sophisticated reaper drone systems from
the us and many other european
governments are turning to washington to
buy drones missiles and other weapons
russia's invasion of ukraine is believed
to have increased demand for u.s arms
the stockholm international peace
research institute says even before
russia went to war with ukraine european
arms imports were increasing
the continent accounted for 13
of global arms transfers between 2017
and 2021 and that is up 10 in the
previous five-year period the uk norway
and the netherlands were the largest
european buyers but it is asia and
oceana who remain the world's biggest
importers receiving a 43
of global transfers since
2017. india tops the world's list while
australia china south korea pakistan and
japan were also among the top 10 buyers
of arms the united states leads the sale
of arms and its export shares rose to 39
percent over the last five years russia
and china have decreased to 19 percent
and 4.6 percent respectively
but beyond the top exporters there are
also many other potential beneficiaries
in the ukraine war turkey has supplied
kiev with weapons including bay rakta
tb2 high-tech drones which have
bolstered ukraine's defenses al
jazeera's defense analyst alex
kotopoulos reports now from the annual
maritime defense expo in doha
turkey's defence exports around the
world have increased dramatically in the
last few years and the standard barrier
for these locally made weapon systems is
the baraktar tb2 combat drone
now it's not the fastest drone in the
world and it's not the most heavily
armed but what it does do is it gives
militaries a cost-effective means of
being able to spot your enemy
being able to destroy them if need be
and also filming those successes
in glorious hd video
we've seen these videos in azerbaijan
northern syria
libya and now over the skies of ukraine
now for turkey this is just the
beginning
they're building equipment like
multi-role helicopters seen here
helicopter landing ships and turning
their sights to fifth generation
aircraft this is only the beginning they
say for turkey's defense exports
alex catopolis for counting the cost
and the defense industry is quietly
making billions of dollars of profit
from the war the potential for a surge
in sales of all types of weaponry has
lifted lockheed stock 8.3 and raytheon
shares 3.9 percent bae systems the
largest contractor in the uk and europe
is up 26
of the world's top five firms by revenue
only boeing has seen a drop
well to discuss all of that i'm joined
from stockholm by pieter vaseman who's a
senior researcher at the stockholm
international peace research institute
mr vaseman welcome to the program so
first of all do you think this heralds a
global rash to buy arms as nations up
their defense budgets or is it just
driven principally by european concerns
about the russian invasion the russian
innovation in ukraine definitely is
going to push european states to acquire
more arms exactly how many we have to
see but that's something which we can
expect which we already saw in the
previous five years that there is an
increase for example in arms imports by
european states but also the rest of the
world there are plenty of other regions
where the tensions are high and where
countries have and also will continue to
invest in new arms the mid middle east
is an obvious region where this has
happened but we can also for example
point at the
major tensions that exist between
japan south korea taiwan the us on the
one hand on the other hand china and
also those will drive continuing large
arms sales and arms
imports by those states
and in fact as you say purchases in
europe were on the up anyway
ahead of this conflict in ukraine uh
following russia's annexation of crimea
correct um that was a very important
reason for european states to revisit
their
defense policies and to look at their
military capabilities and of course that
came at the same time as europe was
climbing out of an economic crisis uh
related to
to the 2008 financial crisis and all
that together already led to a
significant increase in arms imports by
several european states and significant
large orders that have been placed by a
number of other european states in the
past five years you mentioned ongoing
conflicts and tensions
around the world to what degree does
the invasion of ukraine
affect the demand for arms sales around
the world not not just within europe
i think it affects the demand for arms
in several ways in the first place um
europe um at the u.s will look at russia
at the same time is also aware of what's
happening elsewhere in the world and
that will continue to contribute to that
demand for armed in europe where
elsewhere we can also question for
example how will china react to this
will china consider this an opportunity
to step up the pressure how will states
in asia react to that again and will
they therefore also see this as yet an
additional reason to also bolster their
military
capabilities so these things hang
closely together at the same time there
then also made you questions about the
rule that russia can play as a military
supplier from now on
as states may feel that they don't want
to side with russia they may feel that
they are pressured by especially the us
to take a step away from russia
including from russia as an arms
supplier and finally also how states
will deal with the difficulties
of paying russia right now including for
arms that they may buy all right so and
outside of the conflict in ukraine how
concerned should we be about this arms
build-up
i think these bombs build-ups are not
necessarily always leading to war but um
here at supreme and i think many
together with
with
with us
argue that they provide an insight in
the kind of threats that are being
perceived and the
stress that is being put on military
capacity as a tool to deal with those
security threats and that in itself is a
concern and of course it is also a
concern that the increase in arms
imports by one side often leads to an
increase in arms in
imports by the opposing side leading to
reactive arms dynamics and even
potentially to arms races which will not
contribute to peaceful solutions to the
tensions that we see indeed we've been
seeing how european countries have been
buying from the united states but what
about the defense industries on the
continent itself how does it affect them
the
demand for arms in europe that we
already have seen and that we expect to
increase
is is fed by um or is kind of catered
for by industries in
both the us and in
europe the u.s has certain
technology to offer with europe cannot
really match exactly and secondly also
european states feel that they need to
maintain their strong security relations
with the us and buying arms is one
aspect of that at the same time there
are other items which the u.s cannot
supply for example advanced chips that's
something which european states are much
better at right i guess it is in fact
arms manufacturers who are the only ones
who relish a situation like this their
profits just soar at a time like this
yeah i'm afraid that it is true that the
arms in in the industry will
benefit from the war in ukraine um that
is to be expected just like the
pharmaceutical industry has
benefited from
the pandemic over the past two years can
you put a figure on the world's arms
trade
turnover
if you look at the turnover the arms
industry as a whole if you look at 100
largest arm producing companies in the
world what they sell to their own
countries and what they export together
it's something in the order of magnitude
of 550 to 600 billion dollars in in the
most recent year if you look at arms
trade so the trade between countries
then that makes up something like about
120 billion dollars per year that sounds
like a lot it is a lot of course but if
you compare it with the total
manufacturing and the total revenue of
the complete industry in the world it's
only a fraction of that it's maybe one
percent or 0.5 of all exports in the
world right still an extraordinary
amount of money you have to say that
kind of cash could go a long way for
peaceful purposes uh but such as the
world we live in there pieter vinsom
appreciate your analysis thank you very
much
thank you
while arms producers military and
security industries are expanding
profits car manufacturers are being hit
hard by the war in ukraine as it was
fewer people were buying cars because of
the pandemic but after russia's invasion
of its neighbour vehicles could become
even more expensive and difficult to
source ukraine is a major hub for many
components used in semiconductor
manufacturing and car dealers say sales
will be affected by shortages ukraine's
two leading suppliers of neon which
produce about half of the world's supply
of the key ingredient for making chips
have halted their operations as moscow
has intensified its attack on the
country the global supply chains already
face a chip crunch because of the
coronavirus pandemic and that impacts
almost everything we buy from
electronics to cars
the country is also a key source of
nickel ore which is used to make
batteries for electric vehicles and
russia is one of the largest producers
of rare earth metals especially
palladium which is also an essential
metal for semiconductors it's estimated
vehicle production could be down as much
as 15 percent in europe in the first
half of this year
bmw has said that production at its
factories will return to normal after
shutdowns caused by parts shortages
other car makers were forced to slow
production including audi mercedes-benz
and porsche
let's take this on joining us now from
london is andy leyland he's the managing
director at supply chain insights annie
leyland welcome to the show uh the
supply chain was already in deep trouble
then the invasion of ukraine happened
it's made it a lot worse
it has indeed and you know what a lot of
people don't realize is just how
interconnected the supply chains
particularly for the automotive market
is
and you know disruptions that we're
seeing in both russia and ukraine and to
a lesser extent to transport networks
which go through those countries has
really seen the automotive industry
taking a another hit to its supply
chains which were only recovering only
just recovering from uh from the
pandemic so when we talk about this
supply chain being in trouble is that
what it is it's it's the the logistical
issue of getting products from a to b
and you just can't do it through a war
zone exactly and obviously production
stops
in that war zone so we've seen shortages
in things like vehicle components
electrical harnesses coming from ukraine
and then also we see the impact of
sanctions um both on russia and actually
some of the sanctions that russia have
played based on the west in restricting
its exports of particular raw materials
so you know you are seeing impacts there
on markets where you have a restriction
in a relatively small amount of supply
but because of the way that these
commodities are priced that has a huge
impact on prices and costs of production
ukraine is halting the production of
neon
which is a critical component
how is that going to
impact consumers and manufacturers
yeah so the neon market's actually a
really good example of the
interconnectedness of international
supply chains it's primarily used in the
manufacture of semiconductors which as
you may be aware we're already in short
supply
particularly in the automotive industry
so it really further sort of compounds
those problems um there's also a lot of
neon supply that actually comes from
russia as well
which presumably is is going to be
impacted and what that means is all of
these particular semiconductors which
are integral to vehicle production and
all the little computers that you have
in modern automotive vehicles are not
going to be there and you know if you
think of a vehicle as you know
potentially fifteen thousand different
components if you don't have one of them
the the other fifteen thousand are not
particularly useful
right so how are industries and
businesses and car manufacturers gonna
cope
well it's really a sort of short term or
medium term problem um typically when
you are setting up a supply chain you
will have more than one provider so you
go to your other providers to try and
make up the shortfall
that obviously has an impact in terms of
can they increase their production or in
this case probably not because they're
already being asked to um so you either
have to
reduce your your output at least in the
the short term and also you probably
have to increase prices and indeed we we
have already seen uh
production cost increases being passed
on to the consumer for for vehicles and
in particular for electric vehicles
i've noticed it's even had an effect on
hiring cars isn't it the cost of rental
cars was rocketed
yeah and you know that that's an
industry that's really been decimated
over the course of the pandemic with a
lot less business travel and a lot less
tourism and what it's seen is that that
industry has actually had to reduce its
sort of economy of scale um so
effectively you know rental car prices
are likely to be significantly higher
for quite a bit longer until both the
the tourism market recovers and sort of
international business travel as well
and then you've got the knock-on impact
of the the vehicles that they're using
you're more expensive and then obviously
they need to charge that higher cost
need to pass that on to the consumer
with a need to reduce emissions has been
a big push towards electric vehicles
what's going to be the impact on that
well electric vehicles have you know
much newer and less robust supply chains
so when we look at some of the materials
that go into lithium-ion batteries in
particular nickel these have seen really
big increases in price um because of the
supply chain disruption coming from from
russia
and indeed there what you actually saw
in the nickel bike it was a short
squeeze happening over the past couple
of weeks prices quadrupled in very short
order even though they are now settling
back down
and if prices stay at that level you
know that adds uh you know almost a
thousand dollars to the cost of a
reasonable size electric vehicle
and eventually that would need to be
passed on to the consumer and you know
particularly for electric vehicles where
what they're trying to do is come down
in sticker price for those uh so that
they are more mass market available
those price increases really hurt them
because you know ultimately an electric
vehicle is a substitute product and if
it is substantially more expensive then
people will stick to buying uh diesel
and gasoline-powered vehicles
uh briefly andy uh can the car industry
soak this up or are we looking at job
losses
i think certainly the the car industry
will soak it up because demand is still
there
um you may have sort of short-term
production outages at certain plants but
you know the industry is quite resilient
they do plan for this
um and ultimately any any sort of job
losses are likely to be in the the short
term uh due to sort of short-term supply
constraints all right annie appreciate
that andy leyland there
thank you
countries are moving ahead with the
latest generation of 5g mobile networks
but on the african continents many
people hardly have access to the
internet at all in sub-saharan africa
alone nearly a quarter of the population
lacks mobile broadband coverage compared
to seven percent globally but that is
about to change a new underwater
internet cable has wound its way from
portugal to togo it will land in nigeria
namibia and south africa later this year
linking africa to europe the ecuador
subsea internet cable is part of
google's one billion dollar program to
build digital capacity on the continent
and it's expected to deliver 20 times
more internet capacity to the region and
reduce prices by around 14
and that is particularly important for
togo which is among the highest mobile
data costs on the continent at around
nine dollars per gigabyte
the project is the company's third
private international underwater cable
and it's the first in africa google
along with meta microsoft and amazon now
dominate the world's cable
infrastructure meta announced plans to
build at least two transatlantic
undersea cables by 2027 last month but
undersea cables do have a serious
downside the cables can tear and break
leaving entire regions without
connectivity for
days
well joining us from singapore now is
nitin gadria the managing director of
sub-saharan africa at google knit and
welcome to the show
so this cable is really going to be a
game changer for internet access across
africa
absolutely uh first of all thank you for
having me uh we've just uh launched uh
equiano which is what we're calling our
subsea cable that extends from europe
all the way uh along the west coast of
africa down to south africa
we've just had our first landing last
week uh in lomme in togo
uh this cable is is uh remarkable and
i'm really excited about what this
brings to the continent because it
brings in 20 times more network capacity
than the last cable built to serve the
region and the knock-on effects of this
are going to be plenty whether you look
at gdp growth and job creation whether
you look at the growth of digital
economies
uh whether you look at the knock-on
effect on cost of data and internet
speeds and uh internet reliability
across the continent uh some really
exciting things to come down to the
project right and you say first landing
in in togo and togo as a hub i presume
that means it could really reap the
dividends
absolutely uh not just togo but we're
we're going to have uh further landings
uh as we get to nigeria and then down to
namibia
uh as well as south africa as and also
saint helena so uh we are we we do have
landings planned across each of these
countries
and uh togo has been the first one and
absolutely uh you know in interacting
with the government of uh of of togo
over the course of the last week i'm
really excited about the digital agenda
that they built they have a very
deliberate and well thought through plan
for digitization going to 2025
and uh government initiatives across
different parts of of government are
already adopting the digital agenda very
very aggressively and progressively so
i'm really excited about what's
happening in togo
the cable is one thing but the
infrastructure that needs to follow is
another isn't it absolutely so um the
way i see this is this is the starting
point you need the cable uh you you need
this kind of capacity to come into a
particular country a particular region
uh it needs to come into the continent
what needs to happen from here is the
entire ecosystem of
of network players whether that's isps
telcos uh any other uh infrastructure
players uh this entire sector needs to
work together to now bring uh this
connectivity uh deeper into various
countries into landlocked countries and
uh and so on so uh still a lot of work
to be done but this is an important and
essential first step it's a competitive
market important this uh no doubt for
google to get a good foothold in africa
what's the bottom line there i mean
google will profit enormously too i
guess well the way the way we think
about this is uh our core mission is to
organize the world's information and
make it universally accessible and
useful
and uh if you think about the context of
africa there's still about 800 million
people which is a staggeringly large
number
800 million people that have never
experienced the internet so
we're looking forward to the next
several years when these when these 800
million people are going to come online
and we want to create capacity for these
people to come online and have a great
experience on the internet what remains
to be seen is
how these 800 million people use the
internet what they're going to do with
the internet what kind of problems will
they solve what kind of value will they
create with uh with newfound access to
the internet so i'm really really pumped
about what that looks like
one thing these cab cables do have a
habit of breaking don't they you've got
nations economies relying on a on a
bundle of wires lying on the seabed
yeah um
we've again google has been involved in
a ton of uh cable work all across uh the
world and uh our engineers do a
fantastic job of ensuring reliability
ensuring uh
ensuring that there are fail-safe models
built into uh into this kind of work
that we do uh the cable that we've just
laid with equiano is uh is again a
state-of-the-art cable with uh with uh
incredible backup systems built into uh
how this cable is gonna function so i'm
not i'm not concerned about reliability
at this point at all
why did you choose togo as the first
landing point because the initial plan
suggested it would first branch out in
in lagos and nigeria didn't it well
geographically when you sort of go from
uh europe to uh to africa as you sort of
lay uh lay the geography down togo just
sort of comes before uh nigeria that's
that's one thing but in early
discussions with the togolese government
uh what became aptly clear is
uh like i mean like i mentioned earlier
a very clear intention to drive
digitization for togo they have a very
clear digital agenda a very clear plan
to get to 2025
uh which runs across the government last
year we've seen the launch of the first
tier three data center in uh in togo
this year we've seen the landing of
equiano and in in speaking to uh to
various uh government officials in togo
i'm really excited about what they've
got planned so togo was a great first
step but like i mentioned we're looking
at landing this in nigeria in the coming
weeks
uh followed by namibia and south africa
indeed exciting times nitin gadria
appreciate that thank you thank you very
much
and that is our show for this week if
you'd like to comment on anything you've
seen you can tweet me yet nick clark al
jazz please use the hashtag ajcdc or
just drop us an email kind of the cast
at al jazeera.net is our address but
there's more for you online at
alzheimer.com
cdc that will take you straight to our
page which has individual reports links
and entire episodes for you to catch up
on
and that's it for this edition of kind
of the cost i'm nick clark from the
whole team thanks for joining us the
news on al jazeera is coming up